- [Kelly] How do you
celebrate Thanksgiving?
- We usually have a big Thanksgiving,
maybe for 40 people or so.
Everybody wants to come to my house
'cause I raise my own turkeys.
- Sure.
- We have heritage breeds.
Do you know what heritage
breed turkeys are?
- No, but I'm sure they taste great.
- They are really good.
(audience laughs)
I do turkeys three different ways.
- You do three different turkeys?
- Oh yeah, three different ways.
- I love that you said "Oh
yeah" like that's normal.
- For 40 people you need three turkeys.
- Okay, I got you.
- They're 25 pounds each.
We're doing a turkey wrapped in parchment
so you start off baking
it at a low temperature
and then you raise the temperature
and when you take the paper off
- My mouth is watering.
- it gets all nice
and glossy brown skin.
- I bet your turkey's the jam.
- Then we got spatchcock turkey.
Ever do a spatchcock?
- What?
- I'm just realizing that there are
three different ways to do turkey.
(audience laughs)
I'm still stuck on three right now.
- What did you say,
a spatch?
- There are many more
than three ways, spatchcock.
It's nothing dirty, it's nothing dirty.
- It doesn't sound it.
- It means split the cock.
The Hocklets of a rooster.
(audience applauds)
It used to be--
- Somebody's gotta do it.
- It used to be about chicken.
- Somebody's gotta do it, Martha.
- What it means is you
take out the backbone
with a pair of scissors
and you spread it flat
and it cooks in a third of the time.
- Oh!
- So for those of you who are oven poor,
you only have one oven,
you have to bake the pies,
you have to do all the sides,
you have to do the turkey.
- I love that you said over poor.
Most houses have one oven.
(laughing)
I love it, it's amazing.
I want your life.
So you have a show
with Snoop Dogg.
- Once sip of wine
and I'm already giddy.
- Oh, me too.
I'm a lightweight.